[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero
este 17 de mayo se celebra el día
internacional contra la homofobia la
transfobia y la bifobia una jornada que
tiene el objetivo de denunciar y actuar
contra los miles de casos de
discriminación que sufren estos
colectivos cada año que en algunas
ocasiones terminan en la muerte en la
crónica de historia de esta semana
repasamos la lucha del colectivo lgtb
para poner fin a la violencia contra sus
miembros terminar con la marginación
estatal y obtener un reconocimiento
la fecha escogida por naciones unidas
para denunciar la homofobia es muy
representativa ya que el 17 de mayo de
1990 fue cuando la organización mundial
de la salud dejó de considerar a la
homosexualidad como una enfermedad
mental un cambio de rumbo que supuso un
primer paso para poner fin a la
discriminación institucional que han
sufrido homosexuales transexuales y
bisexuales durante siglos y es que el
colectivo lgtb ha tenido que enfrentar
su persecución desde tiempos
inmemoriales
hecho su primera pequeña victoria no
llegó hasta 1791 cuando francia andorra
y haití fueron los tres primeros países
del planeta en despenalizar la
homosexualidad un avance mínimo que
progresivamente comenzaría a tener su
importancia con la llegada de la segunda
mitad del siglo 20 cuando una gran
mayoría de países en europa américa y
oceanía decidieron dejar de castigar la
homosexualidad aunque en muchos otros
especialmente de asia y áfrica se sigue
persiguiendo en la actualidad como
observamos en este mapa 11 países
castigan con la muerte la homosexualidad
ocho de ellos están en medio oriente y
tres en áfrica y hasta 58 naciones
castigan a estas personas con penas de
prisión un número más que significativo
que sobre todo se concentra en áfrica y
en asia aunque también hay ejemplos en
el caribe y en guyana estas situaciones
de injusticia han hecho que el colectivo
lgtb y se movilice desde hace décadas en
busca de más derechos
la fecha más significativa probablemente
sea la del 28 de junio de 1969 cuando se
produjeron los disturbios de stonewall
ese día la policía hizo una redada
discriminatoria en uno de los bares más
reconocidos en los que frecuentaba la
comunidad lgtb y de nueva york y esto
produjo una reacción del colectivo
histórica en defensa de sus derechos que
se sigue conmemorando en una parte
importante del mundo cada 28 de junio en
el conocido como día del orgullo una
jornada que mezcla el ambiente festivo
con el reivindicativo
hasta podemos dar mi rostro este soy yo
este soldado me fue tu trabajo estudio
una gomera nadie tengo mi pareja
complicado mi pareja problema mío y soy
feliz y estoy contexto hizo que las
reclamaciones del colectivo ante lo que
entendían que era una discriminación
estatal aumentaran especialmente en los
países occidentales las parejas
homosexuales reivindicaron sus derechos
a poder contraer matrimonio oa adoptar
de la misma forma en que lo hacen las
parejas heterosexuales unos avances que
no se pudieron ver hasta la del siglo 21
la primera nación del mundo reconocer el
matrimonio igualitario fue países bajos
en 2001 al que siguieron bélgica en 2003
y españa y canadá en 2005
decidimos no ocultarlo sino anunciarlo
nos amamos queremos relaciones iguales a
las de las parejas heterosexuales
a varias de chema web queremos tener una
opción queremos la elección que tienen
las parejas comunes vivir juntas o ser
reconocidas por la sociedad por el
estado
doors durante la última década ha habido
avances en esta materia pero los países
con matrimonio igualitario siguen siendo
una minoría como se observa en este mapa
solo en 31 naciones se pueden realizar
matrimonios entre personas del mismo
sexo destaca especialmente la
legalización en europa occidental y una
parte importante de las américas aunque
también hay casos llamativos como el de
sudáfrica o taiwán el único territorio
en toda asia donde es legal pero la
ganancia de derechos no siempre ha ido
acompañada de tolerancia y respeto hacia
estas personas las agresiones a
homosexuales o transexuales han seguido
existiendo incluso en los países donde
gozan de un reconocimiento institucional
pleno los más afectados aquí son las
personas transexuales ya que según una
amnistía internacional entre 2008 y 2020
3 mil 664 fueron asesinados en todo el
mundo una cifra que se concentra
mayoritariamente en américa latina ya
que cuatro de los cinco países más
afectados son brasil méxico colombia y
venezuela y en europa las agresiones por
parte de grupos de extrema derecha han
continuado
con las reacciones homofóbicas son
increíblemente violentas hay una
libertad de decir cosas que no hemos
escuchado en mucho tiempo
fabricio es como maten a los
es muy violento
las denuncias por delito de odio siguen
estando muy presentes incluso en los
países que tienen una mayor protección
para este colectivo razón por la cual se
conmemora esta jornada el día
internacional contra la homofobia la
transfobia y la bifobia no tiene
solamente el objetivo de reclamar
derechos en los países donde todavía no
existen o de exigir el final de la
condena a muerte o prisión también busca
la protección de estas personas en los
países donde las instituciones brindan
derechos pero no evitan que cada año
mueran personas por su orientación o
identidad sexual con esto concluimos
gracias por compartir y comentar estas
historias que las encuentran en los
programas de france 24 punto com
[Música]